ok ladies and gentlemen good morning and
welcome to this high-level public
conference on implementing the European
Green Deal and on the European climate
law which I know you're all waiting for
which is coming very soon my name is Tim
McPhee and the European Commission
spokesperson for climate action and
energy and I'm your MC for the day so
it'll be my pleasure to introduce to you
our great panel panels our keynote
speakers who are going to talk to you
about the climate law about the Green
Deal and of course who are here to
listen to you as well and this is an
interactive event we'll be taking
questions from the floor throughout all
the panels and of course you have the
coffee breaks the lunch breaks to get to
know each other as well and to work
together on the Green Deal this is not a
one-way conversation a two-way
conversation you're here to build new
relationships new partnerships this is
something which we're all going to be
working on together for the next 5 10 15
20 years and beyond we started a few
minutes late I think there was a bit of
a bottleneck downstairs and I know
there's been a few problems on the
public transport this morning which
means I don't have to talk and I can
straight away introduce you to our first
speaker this morning I'm sure all of you
know him already but I will introduce
him the executive vice president of the
European Commission for the European
Green Deal mr. Franz timmermans and
France please
good morning everyone and welcome to
what I hope is going to be an exciting
day I'm certainly looking forward also
to hearing the conclusions afterwards
this afternoon because we certainly
couldn't use all the help we can get and
if this is to be a a success it can only
happen if it is inclusive if you're all
part of it and if we can agree on the
track to follow
I think you've followed us closely over
the last couple of months we promised to
do a lot in the first 100 days of this
commission and part of that will be the
introduction of the European climate law
so that we can enshrine into law
objective to become climate neutral by
2050 you've seen the presentation of the
Green Deal communication you've probably
also followed the Green Deal investment
plan and adjust transition mechanism
which we introduced a couple of weeks
ago so we're not wasting any time
and by the way a big thank you to
everyone in the service of the
Commission who has contributed to this
we're putting people on the tremendous
pressure but we'll make sure that what
we deliver it continues to be of high
quality and I have to thank my my
colleagues for that so today we're here
to listen to you to hear your views on
the next steps for the European Green
Deal which is the climate law it has to
be your Green Deal it has to be our
Green Deal
so consultation and debate will be and
remain not just today but will remain
essential now let me just remind us of
why this is so important I think that
the scientific evidence is clear tape by
day how quickly and disastrously
consequences of unconstrained climate
change are affecting us we're
increasingly seeing warnings of risks
turning into haunting manifestations of
desire
stur across the globe just look at
Australia wildfires have killed
approximately 1 billion animals 1
billion so sort of double the population
of the European Union it's mind-boggling
and I want to make clear that this is
not me
projecting project fear we're just
reporting on what's actually happening
it is urgent it is essential it is
undeniable that we need to take action
the risks will only increase as the
earth gets hotter and our climate gets
more disturbed climate is changing we
are in a crisis we saw a record number
of cyclones in the Indian Ocean last
year the wettest 12 months on record in
the United States the planet's hottest
August on record and it's happening
close to our home last summer
temperature records were broken in
European countries from Spain to
Slovakia with France recording its
highest ever temperature of forty five
point nine degrees Celsius in southern
Germany the June heatwave hit just after
storms with heavy rain and flooded
streets and cellars and forced the
Munich Airport to suspend its operations
temporarily everyone in Spain is now
very familiar with the phenomenon of
gotough ria which used to happen on an
average of once every 50 years and now
seems to happen almost every year
and even more than once so in November 9
people died as storm swept parts of
France Greece in Italy with flash floods
landslides and the collapse of an
overpass I can go on and on with this
but I think it is good to remind
ourselves of this but without giving in
to paralysis because it's happening and
we can't stop it we can do something
about this this is the most important
thing and then the question is what can
we do as institution as individuals
politicians as businesspeople as
scientists
what can we do people are when I do
interviews very often confronting me
with with a dilemma so what is your
choice do you choose to do something
like climate or do you choose for jobs
do you have any idea what this costs and
I think it is our duty collectively to
explain that choosing to do something
against the climate crisis is choosing
for jobs for future jobs and saying that
choosing to invest in this is much
smarter than not choosing and spending
more money not on investment but on
mitigating or on chale or non at
addressing the challenges which is money
that will be spent but does not bring
any revenues it's not an investment so I
think in our public communication we
will have to concentrate on that to
detect the false contradictions and to
help people understand that doing
nothing does not mean that everything
stays the same that is the biggest trap
in public communication believing that
by doing nothing everything will stay
the same by doing nothing the problem
will get much worse but on the other
side by acting we can actually tackle
the problem because this is in my view
today the biggest biggest challenge it's
increasingly no longer needed to fight
climate deniers
I think climate deniers themselves by
now have understood that they're on the
wrong track and they're not very
convincing but I've seen already the
first climate deniers moving to climate
desperation saying you know why let it
be it's too late let's live it out for a
couple of years let's see what happens
and we saw that we saw some of that last
week also in in Davos
especially one speech of somebody who's
72 years old who was a billionaire and
you know the the issue is that it's its
first generation it's not going to have
severe consequences before the end of
their natural lives if they have a lot
of money they can move to places where
they will be less affected by the
consequences but as a dad of both of two
children from that you can call
Millennials the two children that are
part of Generation Z I listened to those
generations who are thinking about their
future and who are thinking ahead then
you are saying we need to act because
you're playing with our future so I will
not be cornered by people who say
because you you point to the urgency
you're a pessimist and you doom and
gloom we should be optimistic no I think
there is no optimism in denying it
there's no optimism and saying we will
all be okay by doing nothing because
people are too smart to buy that they
might buy just like you know you
sometimes drink too much to forget your
sorrows it is like a way of numbing your
senses by listening to people who deny
all of this but it's like with alcohol
when sooner or later you wake up and you
have a terrible headache and you have to
confront reality you know you you can't
drown your problems and alcohol even
though people will continue to try and
do it and you can't drown these problems
by denying them they will come back even
stronger so in this context what do we
need to do well there's so much we need
to do and and there'll be ample
opportunity to talk about everything we
need to do but my fundamental point is
we can do this we have the science we
have the technology we could certainly
find the money I mean if the Commission
is talking about between let's say 260
and 300 billion
euros yearly to invest in this to make
this transition happen
it sounds daunting but if I was in Davos
last week and I hear what people are
talking about the size of investment
they're thinking about anyway and even
if you just look at the size of
investment that's still being done in
fossil fuels
if you reorient that or at least part of
that into this direction we can find the
money so I repeat the technology the
science the money is not to top so why
is it difficult I think the essential
issue is one of governance is one of
governance how do you organize this like
in any transition especially transition
that is a dual or triple even for Europe
we have the transition because of the
climate crisis Mother Earth is telling
us I can't go on like this and I will
let you feel it if you go on like this
we have an industrial revolution that is
the first in human history that affects
every being on this planet at the same
time never happened before and as
Europeans we also have a demographic
challenge combined with the other two
challenges that changes Europe's
position in the world when my parents
were born Europe accounted for about 23
24 percent of the world's population
Africa 5 in a couple of years time it
will be exactly the opposite that has
huge geopolitical consequences for us
and for everyone and these three
challenges combined will dictate the
policy choices we make and I believe
this is like in any other tectonic
transformation humanity has gone through
is a challenge to everyone and to every
institution so if we deny as political
and public institutions that we will
have to adapt to this or become obsolete
we do help political forces across
Europe and in the world who thrive on
creating this feeling we are
anti-establishment and by the way we
know exactly which minority is
responsible for our
failure and we will make sure that they
will get the blame and we will make sure
that they will be isolated so it is
something we need to do and we need to
do it well and if our premise is and
that's the premise I want to work on
that we leave no one behind we need to
organize it at all levels again I repeat
by doing nothing does not mean nothing
will happen the Industrial Revolution
will happen Mother Earth will continue
to tell us it's enough if we do nothing
that we are no longer in control of
either development but if we act and get
together we can bring some control into
this and why is the climate law so
important the climate law in my view in
my view in simple words is important
because it will discipline everyone in
this process especially on the political
side to take the necessary steps to
deliver on this promise of being climate
neutral by 2050 and it will give the
institutions that need to coordinate
this also the legal possibility to act
when those who make promises don't
deliver on the promises so it is an
exercise in disciplining this
transformational age and I say this in
as a historian with with a keen interest
in studying earlier times of fundamental
transformation whether it's the
introduction of weather it's the
introduction of coal as the basis of the
economy when we went from horses to
steam engines and that when we went for
the steam engines to combustion engines
and now we're going from combustion
engines to other forms of energy
transforming a society that is entirely
based on carbon to a society that no
longer needs carbon as a fundamental
base as a basis for its functioning is
of a tectonic nature and this happens at
a time when digitization
is is wreaking havoc in all sorts of
structures and if we do not understand
that this is not just an economic change
this is not just a change in how we
produce and live this will affect every
single institution upon which society is
based and that helps function society
and if we do not understand that we have
a collective responsibility in preparing
all these institutions to handle this
and to take and to leave no one behind
to take everyone along then we
understand how epic this challenges and
then we also understand that
disciplining ourselves along this path
to 2030 2040 2050 through a climate law
is essential to make sure we deliver on
this and to make sure that we can
correct whenever this occurs but and now
over to you
what do we put into a climate law to
what extent do we want to be
prescriptive how far will it go who are
the subject of the climate law who can
be held accountable if you have a
climate law these are all fundamental
questions where I hope you can give us
some guidance how we can best address
this again as a dad of Millennials and
Generation Z kids I understand this is
an epic challenge it's also an
incredible opportunity for Europe to
lead if we get this right I can assure
you that worldwide there will be huge
interest in studying our idea for a
climate law I get questions about this
and I had it again last week from all
parts of how you're going to do this
we'd like to see this we'd like to be
part of this so it gives Europe I think
at a unique opportunity to lead not just
within Europe but in the world
it gives again speaking ends of that new
generations and ideal again generations
that are no longer based on an
ideological vision of
world but I filled with ideals for the
future of the world it gives them an
ideal to work on the EU climate neutral
in 2050 is an ideal people love to
embrace but people will be horribly
disappointed if we do not start
delivering soon concretely on what we do
and in that context I hope the climate
law can be extremely useful and I hope
we do a good job at the Commission to
drafting the climate law that answers
your requirements it answers your hopes
and that answers your expectations of
the years to come thank you very much
good luck today thank you very much
executive vice president